- What they would say is
they wanted us to lead
because they don't
wanna follow Russia,
they don't wanna follow China,
they do see us as the
moral authority there.
And it was perfect example
was when Trump finally...
When Syria crossed the red
line and did chemical weapons,
and Trump did the first shots
back and did the missiles,
the number of ambassadors
that came to me and said,
it's so good to see the
United States lead again.
(upbeat music)
- I am Dave Rubin and
believe it or not people,
I am live in studio
with a guest.
She is the former governor
of South Carolina,
the former US
ambassador to the UN,
the author of the book right
here in my hands right now
and a real human being.
I can't believe it, Nikki Haley.
- This is so fun.
It's so great to be with you
thank you so much.
- Welcome.
I mean, first, we just
gotta do this part.
I mean, we're sitting just a
few feet away from each other,
I have not done a live
interview in person since July.
My last one was Ted Cruz,
So you gotta follow up Ted Cruz.
We'll see how that goes,
but just to sit
with another person.
- Oh, it's so nice, right?
I mean, we've been
through a lot.
The country's been
through a lot,
but I think the country can't
wait to just be open again
and be moving and start
to live life again.
- Yeah, are you shocked
how long it's been?
I mean, a year and a half later,
it was two weeks to flatten
the curve and here we are.
- I mean, I think
if you had told us
all of this was going
to happen prior to '20,
nobody would have believed it.
But to really see all
the forces at play,
the fear tactics, the idea that
they keeping kids from
school, the masks,
just the over-exaggeration
of everything.
I hope it's taught
a lesson, which is,
look, we all wanna
keep people safe.
We all want to do our part.
But there is a role
that government has
and there's a role that
government doesn't.
And the idea that
small businesses
that we lost thousands
of them through this.
The idea that people
were not allowed
to make their own decisions,
that's a real mistake
and we shouldn't let
that happen again.
- So as a Conservative, do
you think in a weird way
as terrible as this has all been
this has been the best argument
for sort of small
government policies
that people are
kind of waking up.
Look, we're here at L.A
right now in California,
You know my feelings
about this place,
that real world examples
have sort of led people,
I think, to fall more in
the Conservative bucket.
- Look, I think we
have to see this
for the opportunity it is.
It was a reminder that
states should be able
to control what happens
in terms of laws.
We don't need the federal
government mandating down.
States know their people best,
if you look at
whether it was Georgia
when they were the
first ones to open up
and people were
screaming about it.
A governor knows where
their hotspots are.
A governor knows which areas
they have to be careful of.
So allowing governors
to decide that.
But if you look at the
states that stayed open,
versus the states
that closed down,
you had more deaths in the
states that closed down.
I mean, there is something
to personal responsibility.
And when I was governor,
I always thought when
we had hurricanes,
you educate, you give
people the facts,
then let them make
the best decision
for them in their families.
Government doesn't need to
make that decision for them.
And this was a real
lesson during COVID
of it does go too far.
And when you watch the economy
and what we've been through
and the number of
people out of work
and the small businesses
that have closed,
didn't have to happen that way.
- Yeah, so you don't
think that governors
should just pick arbitrary dates
like June 15th as Gavin Newsome
who is now being
recalled should do,
you don't think that
was the best idea?
- I think it's pretty crazy.
I mean, I really do.
I think that the idea
that, well, first of all,
I think he knows a
recall is on the way.
Shockingly California
needs to open up.
No. I mean, I think, look,
people can make good decisions.
I still believe in the
goodness of people.
I still believe that they
are perfectly capable
of knowing what's best for their
children and their families
and what they're willing to do.
And government needs to
just move out of the way.
It's always been that way.
I mean, people have to remember
government breaks more
than it fixes always.
- What did Ronald Reagan say?
What was it the
worst eight words,
I'm going to
slightly butcher it,
I'm from the government
and I'm here to help you.
Pretty much that's what...
Okay. I know we could
do, we could probably do
an hour and a half just on
COVID and all that stuff,
but you sent out
a tweet yesterday
in the midst of this
John Kerry firestorm
that is erupting right now.
So I actually want to
read the tweet and then
we'll give a little
context to what happened.
You said, "This is
disgusting on many levels,
Biden and Kerry have to
answer what for why Kerry
would be tipping off Iran, the
number one sponsor of terror,
while stabbing one of
our greatest partners,
Israel, in the back.
And what this is in reference to
is audio has leaked of the
foreign secretary of Iran,
basically saying that then
secretary of state, John Kerry,
told him about Israel
strikes in Syria.
This seems like a
massive scandal,
but in the 24 hours
since it got out there,
like, yeah, the right
is talking about it,
but pretty much
nobody mainstream,
nobody on the left, but
this seems big to me.
- It is big.
I mean, Biden and Kerry
have to answer for this.
First of all, if it's
true, he can't be--
- I am it's leaked audio of
the foreign secretary of Iran.
- Absolutely.
He can't be in the
National Security Council,
he shouldn't be
a cabinet member.
Biden should answer for
it, Kerry should answer it.
I happen to believe it
and the reason I
happen to believe it
is Kerry and Zarif
were very close.
They worked on the
Iran deal together.
Obama and Kerry
never liked Israel.
They basically stabbed
Israel in the back
even after the election was over
and the UN at the
Security Council,
And so the idea that
you would go and support
and help our number one
state sponsor of terror
around the world, but stab
our friend Israel in the back,
is unconscionable as
anything I can imagine.
But it's so typical of the
Obama 2.0, it's so typical.
And I think it's dangerous.
And I don't trust Kerry,
I don't trust him to
not have done this,
I don't trust Biden to
make Kerry answer for it,
and I think we still
have to be loud
about it because
this is not okay.
- What do you make
generally of John Kerry
because it seems like
he's gotten pretty much
everything wrong forever.
There's videos that go
viral every now and again
of just like all the
things that he has said
that he has just
predicted to be wrong.
- I mean, I just think
he was the one that said
peace in the Middle
East would only happen
through the Palestinians.
He felt like that we had
to be in the Iran deal
because otherwise bad
things were happening.
Yet when I questioned him on it,
I said you knew that this deal
wasn't going to last long,
you knew that within 10 years
they'd be doing
nuclear warheads again.
And he said, well, yeah, we
just knew it was a stall tactic.
Well, stalling is not okay,
fixing is the way to do it.
And so even if it's Biden
getting on this electric bike,
after he gets off
his private plane,
it's just hypocritical at best.
And that's why I don't
think we can trust him,
that's why I think anything
that he gets involved
in he's an elitist.
He's an elitist liberal
who thinks he knows better
than everybody else and
talks down everyone.
- Well, there's that video
of when he was getting
on his private jet,
he said, well I have
important business to do.
That's why I can be
on a private jet.
Not you Peons, you guys
are all just doing nothing.
- It's so hypocritical.
The idea when we
all heard John Kerry
was going to be
back in the cabinet,
in the National
Security Council,
I think we all
took a breath back
because we knew how much
he wanted that Iran deal.
And even though he's
supposedly the climate Envoy,
he's gonna always be weighing
in on all issues of Iran.
That's why I think Biden
needs to answer for it.
And this is really
serious stuff.
- But do you think the
media will do anything?
I mean, that partly
I talk on the show
all the time now about that,
we're basically just
in this reality war.
It's like half the people
will see that story
and be like, oh,
there's something here.
And then the other
half just won't see it.
And then it's like, well
now we're just fighting over
what's actually true.
- It's the reason nobody
trusts media anymore.
I mean, why should you?
You're getting one
side of the story.
You go to any cable network
and you're getting what they
think on one side or the other.
What happened to the days where
you just gave us the facts
and we decided what
we wanted to think?
And I think the days
of those are gone.
So you'll never see CNN
talking about Kerry doing this,
you'll never see MSNBC
talking about it.
And you know, I think we
still have to be loud.
I think we have to push it.
But it's the same
thing with the border
and calm like the border.
We can talk about how many
days she hasn't been there.
But you know, even though, you
know, they're uncomfortable
with the situation,
they won't say anything.
- Well, when they cover it,
they'll say Republican's pounce
That's where they always
say, oh, Republicans pounce
on the thing that we
shouldn't be talking about.
All right.
Let's shift away from that
and it will come back to
like straight up politics
and all that stuff.
But I thought for a second,
we could just talk
a little bit about,
just like your family history
and just like the stuff that
people don't really know.
So what's the Nikki Haley
story that people don't know.
Give me the bio that
people don't know.
- Born in South Carolina.
Small rural town,
two stoplights.
You couldn't think about
doing something wrong
without somebody
telling your mom.
We were the only Indian family
in that small Southern town.
We weren't white
enough to be white,
we weren't black
enough to be black.
- And your parents
were first-generation.
- Yes. My father wore turban,
he still does to this day.
My mother wore a saree.
They didn't know who
we were, what we were,
while we were there.
And I remember when I would
get teased on the playground
and I would come home,
my mom would say your
job is not to show them
how you're different,
your job is to show them
how you're similar.
And it's amazing how
that lesson I learned
on the playground at five,
played out in my life
in the corporate world,
as governor, as ambassador.
Because when you're
faced with a challenge,
if you first talk about the
things you have in common,
everybody lets their guard down.
Then you can go in and
start working on a solution.
- Yeah. So technically you
are a brownish skinned woman,
but you are a scary
Conservative to the mainstream.
Do you find that frustrating,
that you don't get that
little bit of bonus credit
that they might give to
you if you were a Democrat?
- It's always kinda been tough.
When I was elected governor
there was a Conservative
that called me a rag head,
and there was a Democrat
that said I was just a
Conservative with a tan.
I mean, it's never
enough for anyone
but the thing is
minorities in particular
get really offended
when there's a minority
that's a Conservative.
And so yeah, we fight
battles from all sides.
But at the end of the day, you
have to stay true to yourself
and you have to talk
about what you believe
and I feel like
that through my life
even though there's been
hate from different sides,
if you push for the right
thing people see that.
- So you think that American
dream, it kind of works
if you play by the rules.
- It's why I get so upset
when they say we're
a racist country.
I mean, did we have racial
issues when I was growing up?
Yes, but that's the same state
that allowed my dad
to be a professor.
That's the same state
that supported my mom
and her small business.
It's the same state that
allowed me to be governor.
You know, it's the country that
allowed me to be ambassador
and I'm one of millions
of cases like that
where only in this
country can you do
or be anything you want
to be in government
will stay out of your way.
- At least for now.
- We have to make
sure we're always.
But you know even being
at the United Nations,
there's something amazing
when countries would come
and be amazed at how we
had freedom of speech
and freedom of religion and
the opportunities awarded
regardless of where you
were born and raised,
that's special.
And that's why it
bothers me so much
when people criticize America.
We are the best country
in the world hands down,
and we have to fight for Her.
It's worth fighting for.
Because when you see
the countries I've seen
and you've been the
places I've been,
you'd never complain
again if you saw them.
- Are you shocked that it
feels like so many people
are kind of folding right
now and just being like,
oh, this thing, whatever
it is, woke-ness, Marxism,
Cancel culture, it's just
encroaching and encroaching,
and it doesn't seem like a
lot of people are fighting
and you've been fighting
for a long time,
and we'll get to the UN
stuff in a little bit.
- I wish they could
see what I've seen.
If you've been to the
Democratic Republic of Congo,
where they use rape
as a weapon of war,
when you've been to South Sudan
where I've sat
with crying mothers
whose babies were
taken from their arms
and thrown into fires.
When you've been on the
Simon Boulevard Bridge
watching thousands
of Venezuelans
holding the babies in their
hands for hours in the sun
to go get the one meal
they might get that day.
My husband's a combat veteran,
he served in Afghanistan,
and he said, I wish
people in America
could just spend one
day in Afghanistan.
Because even the homeless
here have it better
than what they have
in Afghanistan.
That's what I want
people to remember
is even on our worst day, we
are blessed to live in America.
- Do you sense we're suffering
from our own success
in a weird way then?
- I think we're taking
a lot for granted.
There's a reason if you
speak with legal immigrants,
they are in some ways
so much more patriotic
than people that were born here.
Because they get it,
they get what's
on the other side.
What I want us to remember
is we're not perfect,
we're a work in progress.
But we've gotten it better
than any other country.
And the second you
let this woke culture
and this cancel culture
start bullying people out
of what they believe
and what they think
and what they want
to do to succeed,
don't tear down
the one part of us
that's so great that other
countries envious for it.
- And yet here we are.
- And we're here.
And you know what?
This elections have consequences
and we're feeling the burn.
But sometimes you have to feel
the burn to know where up is.
And we got to start looking up,
we got to start pulling out.
And this is not
the time to whine,
this is not the time to
complain or get lazy,
this is a time to fight.
This is the time we fight back,
we push back for what we
believe in and be proud.
Be proud of this country
because it's given us so much
and there's so much
more it's going to give
our kids and our grandkids.
- All right.
So that probably could have
been your closing statement
but I'm not letting
you out that easy.
So let's back up
for a little bit.
When did you decide
to go into politics
and I guess more importantly,
why did you decide
to go into politics?
- I was never that
political kid.
I never cared about politics,
in high school I was never
in student government,
not in college Republicans.
I had started doing the books
for my family business
when I was 13.
And didn't know that wasn't
normal until I to college.
But really when
times were tough,
I learned how to
stretch a dollar,
I had to figure out
what we're going
to pay and what we weren't,
and when times were good,
we never celebrated.
Because you knew bad times
were going to happen again.
Ended up going to
Clemson, go tigers,
graduated with a
degree in accounting
and then worked for a company
in six of its subsidiaries
as the accounting supervisor,
and then I got tired of working
for the guys down the hall.
And so we came back home
to the family business.
And one day I was
complaining to my mom
about how hard it
was to make a dollar
and how easy it was for
government to take it.
And she said, quit
complaining about it
do something about it.
I did not know you
weren't supposed to run
against a 30 year old
in Congress primary.
I truly didn't,
ignorance is bliss.
But once I realized he was
related to half the district,
and I had thrown my head in,
the only option was to win.
So my husband got in
the driver's seat,
I was in the passenger seat,
we put our two little
ones in the back seat
and I started knocking on doors
and was able to win
that state house seat.
And truly it was, I thought
there were way too many lawyers
at the state house and they
needed a really good accountant.
- Yeah. So then that
was just the beginning
of your political
career, really.
So when did you decide
to take the next step?
- So interestingly enough,
in South Carolina,
legislative votes,
they counted legislative
votes by voice vote,
all in favor, say, aye, all
oppose, the ayes have it.
But one day there was
a piece of legislation
that was right across the desk
that would give
legislators pay raises.
All in favor say aye,
all opposed silence,
and they passed it
and yet to this day, you
can't find one legislator
that said they voted
themselves a pay raise.
- You don't say.
- Republican house,
Republican Senate,
I went to our Republican
speaker of the house
and I said this is why
people don't trust us.
And I filed some legislation
that said anything
important enough
to be debated on the floor
of the house or the Senate
is important enough for people
to have votes on the record.
So the speaker pulled me aside
and he said put the bill away,
we don't need to have it,
we will decide what
the public needs to see
and what they don't.
And I remember going to my
husband that night saying
if I can't even get legislative
votes on the record,
what am I doing here?
And he said, then fight.
So I went around the
state of South Carolina
and said did you know of all
the bills passed in the house
only 8% are on the record?
Did you know of all the
bills passed in the Senate
only 1% was on the record?
So if you did know
how your house member
voted 92% of the time,
if you didn't know how your
Senator voted 99% of the time,
how did you know who to vote
for when you went to the polls?
The people of South
Carolina were shocked.
Now to put this
into perspective,
my first Junior office,
I was chairman of
the freshmen class,
my second year I
was majority whip,
my third year I was on a
powerful business committee,
My fourth year I was
subcommittee chair of banking.
The year that I didn't
put the bill away
they stripped me of everything.
I was completely blackballed,
I could take the well,
no one would listen.
I could sponsor a bill,
no one would co-sponsor.
So I ran for governor.
And one of the first
bills we signed into law
is now in South Carolina.
Everything debated
on for in the house
and the Senate has to
have a vote on the record
and we took it a step further
and did every section
of the budget as well.
- And you had a pretty solid
record in South Carolina.
You're pretty proud
of that record.
- Yes, very proud.
I mean, we went from a
13% unemployment rate
to the fact that South Carolina
didn't have any industry.
All our jobs were in
the textile market
and they had all gone overseas
and we had to wake
South Carolina up.
And so I went in there and said,
if you're costing a
person or business time,
you're costing them money,
that's no longer acceptable
in South Carolina
and we got to work.
And by the time I left, we were
building planes with Boeing,
more BMWs in any
place in the world,
five international
tire companies,
the largest carbon fiber
producer in the world.
They were referring to us as
the beast of the Southeast
and I loved it.
And no unions.
I was a union buster
the whole time,
if there was a company
that wanted to come in
that was unionized,
we strong-armed them
and said we don't want you.
- So what would you say
your guiding political
principles are?
Because it's interesting to me
like you're 13 years
old doing the books,
so like there's numbers
and those things matter,
and now we live in this
bizarre time where everyone's
like 2 trillion for this
and I just saw this morning,
they want to pass another 80
billion to fortify the IRS.
Like what?
Like this, does anyone
look at math anymore?
Do calculators exists?
Like what's going on here?
But did you have a sort of
guiding political principle?
Like when did that sort
of all come together?
- I mean, I really think at 13,
I mean I learned the
value of a dollar
and I learned that that dollar
you can only stretch it so far.
And so really understanding
the value of a dollar,
appreciating small
and limited government
so that people can be successful
without government
getting in the way,
understanding the importance
of a good education
and that education not being
government responding to money,
but government actually
responding to kids
and allowing families to
decide their education
and then allowing job creators
to do what they do best
which is create jobs.
If small business makes money,
they don't go on vacation,
they hire more people.
And so the goal is you
want small businesses
to have cash flow
so they can spread the
tentacles out and do that.
You want a strong foreign policy
where you're making sure
you're safe overseas
and it's not coming here.
These are basic principles,
it's not rocket science
but it's core values that
I think are at the heart
of the Republican party,
but they're at the heart
of a good America too
if we do it right.
- Yeah. So what was it like
the day you got the call,
let's flash forward
a little bit,
the day you get the call,
would you like to be the
ambassador to the UN?
I can only imagine
because there's a
very legion of doom,
scary feeling over at the union.
- The thing people don't
know is Donald Trump
and I knew each other before,
when I won the primary for
governor the first time.
I got this envelope with
this great gold trim
and it was a support check,
and there was a note that
said, you're a winner.
And so I got on the
phone and we chatted
and we we're acquaintances
throughout the years
and then 2016 happened.
And we had a great slate
of talent on that stage,
I put my name behind
a different horse.
- Wait, who'd you
back originally?
- Rubio.
And then that's
when Trump tweeted,
Nikki Haley's embarrassment
to South Carolina,
and I turned around and
tweeted, bless your heart.
We always had a
great respect for,
I knew if you kicked
him, he kick back.
He knew if you punched
me, I punch back.
And so there was
a respect there.
But after the primary,
I threw all my support
behind him and he won.
So when we got the call,
Reince Priebus said he wants
to talk to you about...
He said, don't say anything,
US ambassador to
the United nations.
I said Reince,
I don't even know what
the United Nations does,
I just know everybody hates it.
And so he said, well,
he's going to call you.
So when he called me,
he said, all right Nick,
are you going to do this?
And I said, well, I said,
there'd have to be some changes.
And he said, what?
And I said, well,
I've been a governor,
I don't want to work
for anyone else,
I would want to work
directly with you
so I'd want to be
a cabinet member.
He said done.
I said, well, I'm a policy girl,
So I'd want to be in the
room when decisions are made.
so I'd want to be on the
National Security Council.
He said done.
I said well,
I'm not going to be a
wallflower or talking head,
I need to be able
to say what I think.
And he said, Nikki
that's exactly what I
want you to do this.
And he was true to his word
from the first day
to the last day.
We had a great
working relationship.
- So what was it like
going into the UN?
Because I think you just
described it perfectly.
I mean, it seems like
the most backwards,
at least the security
council stuff,
I know they do some...
I suppose they do some
good humanitarian stuff.
Maybe you can comment.
Well, you can comment
on that obviously
but like to just go in there
and try to at least
defend freedom,
try to get some of
these insane votes
that they're constantly
doing reversed
and change some of that stuff.
Like I'm guessing you were
walking down the hallway.
People were not like, oh,
yay, there's Nikki Haley.
- The UN is not for
the faint of heart.
I mean, every day it
felt like I was putting
on body armor and you
knew we'd have a fight,
you just didn't know which
country we're fighting that day.
But how blessed was I to defend
the country I love so much.
And I was not going to let them
criticize us about anything.
I purposely went in not
knowing the do's and don'ts
of the UN, because I wanted
to kind of be able to ask
for forgiveness and really
go in with fresh eyes.
But I also knew I wanted
to be very black and white.
I wanted to make sure they knew
what United States was for
and what we were against.
And there was no gray area.
I didn't care if they liked me
but I wanted them to America.
And I wanted them to
know where we stood.
Obama had really created
this scenario where
they didn't know
what we were for.
When he tried to appease
everybody by criticizing the US
and he would just
throw foreign aid out
to everyone to buy friends.
I didn't want any of that.
I wanted to make sure that
we really put our line down
in the sand of this
is where we are.
If you want to join us,
we will partner with you
and if you don't, we're
going to call you out for it.
And so that's why I said we
were taking names at the UN.
They thought that
was like unbelievable
that I would say
something so undiplomatic.
But the point was, if you go
around saying death to America,
we're going to take down names.
But if you're our
friend and ally,
we're going to have your
back and take down names
and protect you too.
And so look, it was
a great experience,
it's challenging to
deal with the Chinese
and to have the Russians
always trying to stir the pot
and to have everybody talk
negatively about America.
But I wasn't going
to stand for it.
I went and take one second of it
because I know how great we are.
And I knew what
they were telling me
in the quarters of
how great we were.
- Yeah. So that that's
actually exactly
what I wanted to ask you.
So like, I would imagine that
the country secretly believe
that most of the countries.
Like they secretly must be like
yeah, the us doesn't
exist in freedom,
then we're all kind of screwed,
but then they
rarely vote that way
or publicly they say all
these ridiculous things.
- No. They bash us publicly
but what they would say
is they wanted us to lead
because they don't
want to follow Russia,
they don't want to
wanna follow China,
they do see us as the
moral authority there.
And you know it
was perfect example
is when Syria crossed the red
line and did chemical weapons,
and Trump did the first shots
back and did the missiles
the number of ambassadors
that came to me
and said it's so good to see
the United States lead again.
Like that's what they want.
They want us to call out evil,
they want us to do good, they
want us to show something
and that's why I've always
said the United States
leadership isn't going to war.
Sometimes just when
the United States
says something,
countries follow.
When we mentioned this
is what should happen,
they do tend to move with us.
And so there's good
that we have there
but we have to continue
to use that voice
and be a force for good.
- Can you explain
either your philosophy
or Trump's philosophy or
both of your philosophies,
just generally on when you
should use the military?
Because I think a lot
of people think somehow
if you're for the military,
that means you were for war
and it's actually the reverse.
- And that's not
the case at all.
I mean, the key is look,
I'm in a military family,
so the last thing
I'm going to say
is with my brother was full-time
military, my husband is,
the last thing you want your
family members to go to war.
But the military is
there for a reason.
And what you do
want is for example,
with Biden wanting to
pull out of Afghanistan.
Well, my husband
served in Afghanistan,
I know what was happening there,
we don't need thousands
of troops there
but you do need some
there for intel purposes.
That's really what you want
is military for intelligence,
to tell you on the
ground in Syria
whether they're getting ready
to do a chemical weapons attack,
to tell you on the
ground in Afghanistan
whether there's
another plot for 911.
So the only thing I'll say is
that Biden's Foreign Policy
is really backwards in the
way that look at how much
has changed from the Chinese
delegation comes to Alaska
and humiliates our
American delegation.
Putin's challenging
Biden to a debate,
how ridiculous is that?
Chema is starting to test
off ballistic missiles again,
and here Biden's
falling all over himself
to do business with Iran
but is boycotting Georgia?
Like these things and
then all of that--
- Georgia the state not
Georgia the country.
- Absolutely.
And all these things and he's
cutting our defense spending.
I'll be the first one to
say the military is bloated,
it's bureaucratic,
there's a lot that we
shouldn't be paying for,
but if we don't
modernize our military,
China and Russia already moving,
Iran is already speeding up,
we look so distracted right now.
And making sure we
modernize our military,
making sure we have strategic
military on the ground
in certain places
to keep us safe
and to keep bad actors
from doing more harm,
that's an important thing.
- So what do you
think is behind Biden
and the decisions he's making?
This is the question
that everyone gets
asked all the time.
Like, because I think most
people don't really believe
it's Biden leading
this thing anymore,
that it's either the
Obama machine behind it
or something that's left
of the Clinton machine
or something else altogether.
Like, to me it seems like if
you would've asked Joe Biden
10 years ago, if he
agreed or disagreed
with some of the things
you just said there,
he probably would have
agreed where now it's like,
who knows what he believes.
- What it feels
like to me coming
in the transition from Obama
to the Trump administration
and Foreign Policy
and now where it's going,
it really does feel
like Obama 2.0.
I mean the idea that they're
already trying to make friends
with Iran that was very much
something Obama would do.
The idea that they're like
starting to pick fights
with Russia in a
strong man sense
but not in real results sense,
that's something Obama would do.
The Paris Climate Agreement,
the Human Rights Council,
all these things,
these Trump reversals are
very much Obama stances.
And so I think that that's
the approach Biden's taken.
He surrounded himself
by Obama people,
whether it's secretary Blinken
or Jake Sullivan
or any of those,
those are all Obama people
that would be advising him
on what Obama wants.
- So what can be done at
the international level
like with the UN at this point?
Like if you were
there right now,
which probably ain't
going to happen,
but if you were there right now,
I mean, this just in
the last couple of days,
Iran got put on the, was it
the Women's Rights Council?
- The Women's Council.
I mean, how ridiculous is that?
- Like all these people
are laughing a bit but--
- And it was not only
Iran, it was also China.
This is like an absurd.
- But who makes these decisions?
Like someone goes into meeting
and they're like, yes, yes,
let's put her on the
Women's Rights Council.
Like how does that even happen?
- It's why the United Nations
doesn't have credibility,
it's why they struggle.
First of all, if I was at
the United Nations right now,
I would immediately call
a security council hearing
and hold China accountable
for what they did
to the world with COVID.
I would ask what the World
Health Organization knew.
I would call out Iran
for all of the violations
of UN resolutions
that they're doing
and say how can you turn around
and get into an Iran deal
when they're violating
multiple resolutions.
There's a lot of things
that could be done
and should be done,
and instead what we've seen
is the UN ambassador went
and basically
criticized America.
- Was there any speech that you
had heard in the last couple
of years that were just
more awful than that?
- Modified.
That here I was
defending America
and here the Chinese
delegation goes
and humiliates the
American delegation
and the UN ambassador
basically gave them
all the fuel to do it.
We are not a racist country,
we are the least racist country.
And so the idea that they
would say that it's such a...
I can't even
understand what Biden
or the ambassador think that
will do to help America.
That's apologizing for America.
- I don't think they want to
help America at this point.
That's what I mean about Biden,
I don't know what Biden believes
but I think the machine
that's under him or behind him
or whatever it is like, do
they want to help America?
- It was so embarrassing.
It made me sad.
I mean, you talked about
what can the UN do?
What is it good for?
The reason presidents struggle
with staying in the UN
is not because of any
great actions by the UN,
we see that all the time.
I think the reason they
stay is because of the veto.
There are only five
countries that have a veto
on the security council in
the UN, Russia, China, US, UK,
who am I missing, France.
So if you look at those,
if bad things happen,
if Russia and China
try and get together
and do something bad,
the US can stop it.
That's the reason that we're
on the security council
is we can stop bad
things from happening.
But they waste more
than they should ever...
I cut $3 billion the first
year off of that budget.
And that was just low hanging.
- And the lights didn't go out.
The building still existed.
- And people see
that big building
and they think they're
ambassadors in there,
that's all staff.
They've got elevator
operators in there.
I would say, do you
know how many vaccines
you could give kids
with what you're paying
these elevator operators?
They doubled their staff
in the last 10 years.
- And don't they...
Wasn't there some
massive scandal
where they were like
racking up something
like a hundred million dollars
worth of parking tickets
in New York city?
Like it's just crazy over there.
- It's so ridiculous.
China is infiltrating
the entire UN.
They are trying to really,
I think they now control
four different agencies
within the UN, Russia
controls the cyber agency,
believe it or not.
China almost started controlling
the intellectual property
and we were able to stop
that from happening.
But I mean, it's just, the
UN will not be relevant
until they start
talking about the things
that are uncomfortable
to talk about.
The Uyghur genocide
that's happening in China,
the fact that--
- They won't even have
a meeting about it.
- They won't even do it.
- So what do we do with China
or what do we do with China?
Like are we on some
inevitable collision
no matter what here?
Just because of debt
if nothing else,
like if they just call in,
hey guys you gotta pay us
back for some of this stuff.
And then it's like, well, we
can't, we don't have the money.
and we do have
missiles and bombs.
- It's actually pretty scary
what's happening right now
because China is our number
one foreign policy threat.
But the concern
I have is America
looks so distractive right now.
Like everything, all these
countries see us as distracted
but China is in this
for the long haul.
And the US at some point
has to quit thinking
about things in terms of
presidential elections.
We've got to start thinking
20 and 30 years out,
what does our foreign
policy look like?
If you look at China,
they have the largest
Naval fleet in the world,
they have more missiles
than we do now,
they're building
up their military,
we've got to start
modernizing ours.
They are continuing to
steal intellectual property,
we've got to start
holding them accountable
for every time they steal
that intellectual property.
- What does that actually mean?
Because what do we
have at this point
beyond the threat
of military action.
Like we're not bombing
China tomorrow.
- Look, sanctions
and stopping business
with China is a
big deal to them.
Humiliating them and calling
them out is a big deal.
They have a million
Muslim Uyghurs
that are in concentration camps.
If you saw what was
happening there,
it's horrific, it's
rape, it's sexual abuse,
it's physical abuse,
it's forced slave labor,
I mean, making them
change their name,
change their religion, drink
alcohol for the first time
just to break them, I mean,
it's a horrible situation.
We swore years ago, never again,
would we turn our eyes away
from genocide and it's
happening right now
and no one is calling
China out for it.
It's the reason why
they get so important
that we boycott the
Chinese Olympics,
is because in the last Olympics,
the way Beijing looked
at it was the last one
that they hosted was
their coming out party.
This one, mark, my words,
this one is them saying
we are the new
superpower of the world.
And after that Olympics
they will go and
try and take Taiwan.
And if they take Taiwan,
that's a total game
changer around the world.
And so they're trying to get
as much good press as they can.
If we call them
out, they hate that.
So making sure that we
call them out on genocide,
making sure that we actually
hold them accountable
on intellectual property,
modernizing our military
which scares them
or having a military presence
anywhere scares them.
You go and you look at
what president Xi did,
he started a commission
that basically
said any company that
does business with China
has to cooperate with
our Chinese military.
Now think about
our tech companies,
think about all the information
they have on our habits,
on our pharmaceuticals,
on everything we do
and now know the Chinese
military has access to that.
Think about that.
Like that's dangerous and
we watch this play out
in real time with COVID,
that when we were trying
to save millions of lives
what was China doing?
They called to
American companies,
3M and Honeywell who
have business in China,
said you are not allowed
to sell any of your PPE.
They'd bought it wholesale,
and they would only
give it to countries
that agreed to do business
with Huawei, their 5G network.
This is a country that is out
to really take over the
world and do all that.
That's what all these
investments around the world are
is when they're
running up this debt,
then they go and they say
to these all countries,
okay give us your
military and such,
give us your utility and
the debt that we're in,
is the first time our debt
is bigger than our economy
since World War II.
Do you know what that does?
Makes China so happy
because when you weaken
the dollar like that,
that's a national security
threat beyond anything else.
There's a reason China and Iran
just got into a bank together
is they're trying to make
sure that the US dollar
is no longer the
world's reserve.
And we're sitting back
and watching this happen
and not doing anything about it.
- So do you think no one in
the administration gets it?
Because I think most people
watching this are probably,
even if they're not that
in the weeds on all this,
they're probably like,
yeah that does feel
like basically what's happening.
That China is saying we're
going to be the new superpower
and they're setting up
all the pieces in play.
But do you think anyone,
do you think the
administration cares?
- I think the US is
playing to symptoms.
So they see what China's doing
and they're treating
like symptoms
but they're not
treating the disease.
That China is a disease that
we have to stop thinking
if we're nice to them,
which Kerry just said,
oh, we should be nice with China
so we can cooperate
on the environment.
We have to stop thinking
if you're nice to China
they'll want to be like us.
They don't want to be like us.
They want to be communist.
They're going to continue
to do whatever it takes.
They're laughing
at us right now.
What we have to do is let
China know we're onto them
and we have to act accordingly.
Now that doesn't mean
that they can't buy grains
and poultry from us,
or we can't buy T-shirts
and light bulbs from them,
but it does mean they don't get
to control our pharmaceuticals.
We don't need to go in so
much debt that they own us.
Like there's certain things we
just need to be smart about,
strategic about, instead of
just curing the little symptoms
that come up along the way.
- Do you think part of the
problem with some of this stuff
is that now and I think
you were alluding to this,
that now so much of our
conversation is about race,
it's about all of this internal
stuff here and woke-ness
and cancel culture and all this,
but the idea of this big problem
that like sits there people are
just like, oh, I don't know,
we got enough problems here.
Even though I think in many ways
our problems here are
completely fabricated.
- We do have big problems here
and we do have big
problems overseas.
We should be able to handle
both at the same time.
Like it's not an
either or scenario.
- You are saying we can
do two things at once?
- I mean, there's
something to be said
for balance and prioritizing
and making sure that
everything is in its order
and you talked about
the race aspect.
I mean, one of the things
that was so appalling
to me is what happened
with the Georgia bill.
South Carolina when
I was governor,
we passed voter ID in 2011
much tougher than
the one Georgia did.
And I said at the time,
if you have to show
picture ID to buy Sudafed,
you have to show picture
ID to get on a plane,
you should have
to show picture ID
to protect the election process.
I was vilified at
the time they said
that I was trying to
disenfranchise voters,
that a lot of people
couldn't get picture IDs,
and I said, okay, fine.
If that's the case,
I will send someone,
we will pick you up, we
will take you to the DMV,
we will get you
a free picture ID
and we will return you home.
- I know the numbers So
I'm going to say yep.
How many people went
in on that program?
- After 5 million people, 25.
25 people asked for a ride.
The number of
people that now vote
in South Carolina is higher.
The part that was so offensive,
don't assume minorities
can't get a picture ID.
Don't assume we can't
go get a picture ID,
pick the schools
we want our kids to go to.
It's actually Democrats
that are racist
that treat us like we
are inferior, incapable,
and it's offensive on so
many different levels.
- Well, it's also specifically
racist to black people
because even though
you're saying we,
you know they don't
mean Indian people.
Like that's part of the odd
position that Indians are now in
that Indian-Americans are now
in as a successful minority.
- Look at this, so they're
sitting there and they're going
through all this stop
Asian hate all of this
but why was it the Democrats
that shot down the part
that said stop discrimination
of Asians in schools?
- Just in the last
couple of days.
- So it's just
hypocritical in terms
of what they think is
racist and what's not.
When you're Brown,
it's almost worse
because they think
you're not black enough
or you don't count or
they can discriminate
against you in schools but
hey, don't mess with them
when they're trying to vote.
All of these things
but all of that does
is it assumes
minorities are dumb
and it assumes
minorities are less then
and it's Democrats
that are doing that
and we have to keep calling
them out on how racist they are.
They see what too
many Republicans do,
too many white
Republicans frankly do
is when they call you
racist, they just back down.
They go into a corner.
Don't do that, we're not racist.
It's the reason why I'll say
this until my last breath
is we are not a racist country.
Do we have some bad eggs?
Always, but so
does everyone else.
But we have progressed over
the years over and over again.
You can see it
through all the things
on how women are empowered,
on minorities are empowered,
everything people have
been lifted up in total.
That's what you want to
continue to see happening.
- How badly did the Republicans
just screw up the
messaging on this?
Like, do you have any sense
of sort of when it happened?
Because as a guy that's kind
of new to this side let's say,
the right or the Conservatives
or whatever it is,
I went to a ton
of Trump rallies,
I've been to anti
lockdown rallies,
I've spoken at Turning
Point USA things,
I have never once,
I swear to you,
ever heard anything
remotely racist ever.
And in Q&A's when someone
might ask a question
that could kind of sound that
way, they shoot them down.
But it's like how
did Republicans
just become such wet paper
bags and just fold over this?
- It's actually
what Democrats did.
So when Democrats
ran out of excuses,
they started saying
that they were racist
and they immediately
saw Republicans cower.
They immediately saw
Republicans cower.
The thing is,
Republicans are too nice.
They're too nice.
- Is it nice or is
it just thinking
that the government's
not the answer?
So you just don't want
to be in that fight
in a way that they do.
- They're too nice
like you fight back.
If you know, we're not
racist, say you're not racist.
If you know, we're
a good country, say
we're a good country.
Don't let them yell us down
because we're the
ones that are right.
So go back and fight for it
and that's the only part
is I don't want people
to get tired, we don't
have time to get tired.
We have to get strong
and we have to fight back
because if you let them
get away with this,
they will only continue
to do it more and more.
I mean, look at
what has happened
because of this
racist conversation,
the idea that we've gotten
into defunding the police,
the idea that you want to now
hold police officers liable.
These are the kinds of things,
but they're doing it all
in the name of racism.
And there's a
miscommunication there.
I do think--
- And by the way
they're reversing it
right after they do it.
Portland is now reversing
a lot of the policies.
- Absolutely.
And look, I do think that race
is an important
issue in America.
It's one that needs to be
dealt with with respect,
it's one that needs
to be understood.
and it's one that you need
to have a good conversation
that's educated and respectful
that can move the ball.
And there's a time
and place for that.
I had to do that in South
Carolina multiple times,
but when it shouted down
and done in judgment,
that's not goodwill.
That's just sitting
there fighting to fight.
- So this is my
million dollar question
then with that in mind,
what do you think the future
of the Republican
party looks like?
Because I've been
saying something
for a few months now that
in essence right now,
the war let's say is sort
of woke or conservative.
And I don't mean
conservative meaning you have
to have a picture of Ronald
Reagan next to your bed,
but that we know what woke is
and then it's sort
of everybody else
and we can disagree on tax rates
and I think we can actually
disagree on abortion
and a slew of different things.
But what do you think
that that big chunk
actually looks like?
Like what kind of diversity
in a political sense
can we get out of that?
- So what I would like to think
that the Republican
party will be,
is it won't go back to
the party before Trump
because that was a really
important move that we made.
So many people like where I
grew up in rural South Carolina,
who felt unheard, misunderstood,
not paid attention to,
suddenly came into the fold
and they made our party better.
The problem is we lost
women, we lost the suburbs,
but more importantly, we
have to expand our tent.
We've got to reach
out to Hispanics,
we've got to reach out
to the Jewish community,
we've got to reach out to Asians
and make sure that we
have that conversation.
African-Americans I did
it in South Carolina,
it can be done, but
you don't go to them
and say you should be one of us.
You go to them and say,
what do you care about?
And when you have
that conversation,
suddenly they realize you
care about the same things.
And then you have
a conversation,
I know if I went and
spoke to several hundred
Indian Americans right
now, 70% would be Democrat.
But if I just showed
up with respect,
had a conversation
we'd win half of them,
it takes more work,
it takes more time,
it takes more effort,
but if we do it, we
will be a better party.
Do you know, we've lost
the last seven out of eight
popular votes for president?
That means we're
doing something wrong.
If we grow our tent,
if we grow our party
we will be a stronger country
and we will be able
to move the ball
not for the next
presidential election,
but for 20 and 30 years down
the road, we have to do it.
- Do you think some of that
stuff can actually be healed?
Like right now and you can't
judge things by Twitter
I know that much, but
there does seem to be this
like tension between whatever
the sort of MAGA camp is
and then the pre-MAGA people
and it's like how do
you get these people
to kind of like you seem to
me to be like a synthesis
of those things, but
like how do you do it?
Because there seems to
be a lot of resentment
from the MAGA people
to the old ones
and then the old ones
to the MAGA of people
and the whole thing.
- I think the first thing
is the judgment has to stop.
There's way too much
judgment of people.
There's an unforgiving
side of just toxicity
that's happening right now.
And so what I think
we have to understand
is everyday Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris are an office
is another day we
should come together.
But we are better together.
You can fight each other all
you want, it is not productive.
We are better together.
We have a bigger enemy out
there and that's socialism
and it's going to happen if we
sit there and keep fighting,
all it's going to do is
open the door to socialism
and we're going to end up
having to walk right through it.
And then we won't have
time to go back and say,
oh we should have.
So come together.
I respect both sides.
It goes back to
in South Carolina
when we removed the
Confederate flag.
We had had a terrible
tragedy, it was a tough time
and in that removal of
the Confederate flag,
when I called for
it to be removed,
I was very aware of two things,
half of the state saw the
flag as heritage and ancestry.
The other half of the
state saw it as hate.
My job wasn't judge either side,
my job was to get them
and move the ball forward.
And so when you
take judgment out,
then all of a sudden people's
defenses are not there,
then they listen.
And I worry right now that
there's a lot of judgment
going back and forth.
Don't shoot your sisters
and your brothers,
we're in this together.
We're one big family and
we've got to move forward
but we move forward in
the conservative ideals
that we all hold dear.
We move forward because
we know socialism is bad,
we move forward because we
know big government's bad,
we move forward because
fiscal responsibility matters
and all of those things
can work together
if we're all on the same page.
- What kind of pushed back did
you get from your own people
when you started talking about
the flag after trial or so.
- A lot. A lot.
I think that anytime
you do something,
you're never going to please a
hundred percent of the people
and that can't be why you do it.
You do it because you
can see something bigger
and a better place
forward for all people.
And so, South Carolinians
there were many
that were very upset
with me that I did that
but at the end of the day,
South Carolina is a
better state for it
and they saw that afterwards.
And we didn't have
riots, we had vigils,
we didn't have
protests, we had hugs.
I mean, we did it in a way
that the national media
didn't tear us down.
We did it in a way
that was respectful,
that moved the ball
and that's what you have to do.
There was another a month
prior to the church shooting,
we had the shooting
of Walter Scott.
Killed, shot seven times in
the back, unarmed black man.
This was right after Ferguson.
I just was so worried our
state would fall apart.
The first thing I did was
called the Walter Scott family
and say we will get
answers for you.
If you will allow me this time
I will get you everything
you need to know
and we will make sure
his life wasn't in vain.
The next call I made was
to law enforcement saying,
we've got to fix this,
let's do this together.
A month to the
day South Carolina
passed the first body
camera bill in the country.
And when I signed that bill,
I had the Scott
family on one side
and I said never again
will a dirty cop do
to someone without
us having proof.
And then I had law
enforcement on the other side
and I said never
again will a good cop
be accused of something bad.
You have to be willing
to see the greater good
and you have to be willing to...
I mean, one leadership
is not letting the two
sides kill each other,
not letting the two
sides blame each other
but getting the two
sides to understand
we all are trying
better for better things
and that means we all
got to give a little.
- Do you think oddly that
a lot of the Democrats
now are doing the complete
reverse which is sort of nodding
to the violence that we're
seeing on the streets
and they don't mind when
this chaos is erupted.
- It's a real problem.
When you go, it doesn't
make sense when you have
these violent protests
and you're tearing down
an African-American
small business
or you're seeing
an African-American
police officer shot.
Like these things, you're
hurting your own people.
I mean at the end of the day,
the protests and the violence,
if you're upset I
get it, I get it.
But do it productively in
a way that we move the ball
because hurting the community,
whatever color you are,
that's not moving the ball.
That's only hurting
more people--
- But are you shocked?
Are you shocked
that no Democrats?
I mean, really no.
Democrats are...
Joe Biden is still only
saying Antifa is an idea,
an idea that's caused about
$2 billion worth of damage.
- Absolutely.
No.I think that they fail to
see what they don't want to see
and they immediately
judge and go after
what they want to
assume as the culprit.
And it's harmful for our country
and something has to change.
And our job is again,
not to sit back and say,
it's done we can't do anything.
No, you keep saying something,
you keep correcting them
and do it unapologetically,
do it with courage,
do it with strength
and do it with passion
because when you do that,
they don't have the standing
to really keep going.
Because if you were to question
what's racist and what's not
or question protests
and they can't say more
than a second sentence
because they have no other
explanation after that.
- That's kind of why they're
into that censorship thing too.
There's a little
something to that.
So to that point, we
sorta touched on this
but one of the reasons that I
came around on Trump was I saw
that it wasn't just
Republicans fighting Democrats,
it was Republicans versus
Democrats and the media.
And he was just like,
I'm not going to take it.
What do you think Republicans
can do in that fight?
Because I get a lot.
I hear a lot of people now
that are really regretting,
my few good liberal friends
that are still talk to me,
they're not happy with Biden.
But what they're saying
is we still had to get rid
of Trump because
of the way he spoke
and all that kind of stuff.
But to me, it was like, he
knew how to fight that thing
and you're not going to get
the perfect guy to do that.
Like, what do you think
Republicans can do?
Like you can see them doing
this with DeSantis now though,
that awful 60 minutes
hit piece and everything.
I was like what do
you think Republicans
can do in that arena?
Because that's not
the political arena,
that's more the media arena.
- I mean, I think we've seen...
Look, I've been hit recently
by a liberal reporter
that will go out and
they'll do profiles
and they'll try
and shoot you down.
- Are you talking about
that political piece?
I read it this morning.
I don't want to give
them the clicks,
but I read it this morning.
The first paragraph alone,
well first of it's fiction.
They actually write
it as a fiction story.
- There were so many
untruths in that story
but that was meant
to be a hit job.
They knew exactly...
It didn't matter what I said,
they wanted to fit it
into their narrative.
And that's what the media
does is they take it
and they've already
got the story written
before you say the first word.
And what we have to
do is call it out
and say this is a lie,
this is wrong, whatever.
But boy, we have to
keep pushing back
and again, that's why
the media is not trusted
but it's a real problem.
It's a problem because
there's more liberal outlets
than there are
conservative outlets.
And so the liberal outlets,
anyone that they think
is starting to rise
or get a louder voice, they're
going to shoot you down
and they're going to
find some way to do it.
- I don't want to
link to the piece
but maybe we'll put an
image up or something
from the piece because
it was so extraordinary.
It's literally
written as fiction.
- It's the worst and
the amazing thing is--
- It's hard to really
make me be like,
whoa at this point because
I've been through it,
but like I was--
- Not only that 95% of what
I said about Trump was good
and he was angry about
it, he was mad about it.
And then the 5%
that I said related,
they acted like I woke
up with an epiphany
that something happened.
The problem with articles
like that is they are trying
to change the political
dynamic on their own.
They're trying to create
the story on their own
because they know the
Democrats don't have a bench.
They know that they don't
have strength behind them.
So they think the best
way to do it is just
tear everybody down and
do it in different ways.
And we're watching it happen
to all of our Republicans.
They'll just tear you
down one at a time.
They'll find some way to do it.
And I don't know
what the answer is,
I just know that we don't
cave, we keep fighting.
- Do you think that
basically conservatives
and again I mean that in
sort of the wide sense of it,
just have to start building
completely new things.
I mean, this is
sort of a new idea
that's out there
now which is like,
in essence conservatives will
have to have their own banks,
they'll have to have their
own places of journalism,
own educational institutions,
that at some level these things
are just irreparably damaged
and we should just
let them have it
and the rest of us will
build better things.
- I mean, I don't know that
it's irreparably damaged.
I mean, I think that the
media misses Trump terribly.
I think they're so bored.
I mean, I was in the
airport the other day
and a reporters chasing
me down the airport
and I'm like, this
is what have left.
I think that the idea is
they miss his tweeting,
they miss the stories because
it provided something everyday
and their ratings
went through the roof.
Now their ratings are not
going through the roof.
People are watching less news
because they're tired of it,
people are not getting
as much benefit from it
because there's no substance,
it's more opinion
than it is facts.
And I think people are done
but I do think conservatives
should support conservatives.
Whether it's businesses,
whether it's media outlets,
whether it's something else
or whether it's
creating your own,
is don't feel like you
have to deal with it,
let's find ways to make
our own side better.
Let's find ways to fix it.
- So when I've talked to my,
let's say left leaning friends,
about this new
conservative movement,
the two that still get them,
it's always the same two
it's abortion and belief
that most of them come.
Not that they're
all purely atheists
but they have this
real thing about,
oh, the right it's
just too religious
or something like that.
So could you kind of sue them
perhaps on either one of those?
My example, I'll just
tell you is Rudy Giuliani
is obviously a conservative
and he was obviously
a Trump supporter
and not only when
he got divorced,
oh because then they'll also
say the gay thing a little bit
which I think the ship
has sailed on that,
well, he lived with two gay
guys after he got divorced,
he's pro choice and he
was a Trump supporter
so it's like, nobody's doubting
that he's a conservative,
so I see a wider tent there.
What would you say about that?
- Look, I mean I think
we all have our views
and I think again, lack
of judgment is important
as you go for.
I just don't believe in
being a judgmental person,
I don't think anybody
else should allow them
to go into that
negative energy either.
But look, I mean
conservatives are...
I'm a person of deep faith
I think that God has
blessed us in so many ways
but I use mine as it's like
my parents always said,
the best way to appreciate
your blessings is to give back.
So it's more of like a
service that you feel
that you give back.
If you've been blessed with
goods, you try and pass it on,
you try and hold
the ladder down,
you try and help other people
and you know that
there's a higher power.
Some people don't believe
in that and that's okay.
That's not something that I
would ever judge someone for it.
Same thing with the pro-life.
I'm pro-life not because the
Republican party tells me to be
but because my
husband was adopted
and I'm blessed
every day for him.
And so I think experiences
are what form us
but at the end of the day
we have to look at
the greater good
and figure out how we get there.
And so I also don't think
we're all one issue people.
I mean, the way the
Democrats always assume women
are so divided on
the pro-choice issue.
- They are so for women
but I always say they're
not for Nikki Haley.
There are so for women,
they are for black people,
they're not for Candace Owens.
- I mean, my thing is
like, that's just ludicrous
to think that one issue
should make or break us.
I don't agree with my husband
a hundred percent of the time,
it doesn't mean
that I don't love.
And I think that anytime they
try and one issue us off,
that's again
desperation to do that.
- Do you think part of this
is sort of just the politics
as religion that
something has shifted
in the way we talk
about politics now
that everything is
political everywhere.
I don't watch, I got a
basketball behind me,
I don't watch the NBA
anymore because I couldn't.
Partly was because
of the China thing.
I'm watching LeBron won't
say a word about China
and they have Black Lives
Matter on the court and yeah.
What do you think about that?
- I think politics has gotten
too involved in everything.
And that's the thing
is I feel like it's all
about soundbites and it's
not about substance anymore.
So people are just spouting
off things that are hateful.
I don't know if COVID
exacerbated that,
I don't know whether it's
social media that's done it
but people are so quick
to say hateful things
but they won't do
it in person yet,
but they will do it
through the media.
- If you got one of this.
- They'll do it in
every other way.
So I do hope that calms down.
I mean politics should
never be a hundred percent
of anyone's life.
Politics for a lot of
years may have been my job,
but I never took it home.
I have friends
that are Democrats,
I have friends that have
different views than I do,
I watch movies with
actors that are Democrats,
I'm not one of those that
says you can only listen
to conservative musicians.
I appreciate all
of those things.
I think there's a
place for politics
and I think that's
at the voting booth.
And I think that's
in making sure
that you're supporting
candidates and
that's making sure
that you're moving
the ball on policy
but the rest don't forget
to love your neighbor.
It still matters.
- Gosh, I really forgot how
much I love just sitting across
from somebody and not staring
into a screen all the time.
So before I ask you the
one that you probably
don't want to be asked,
the last question,
I didn't look at my
notes this entire time.
I was with you the whole time,
is there anything
else that you want
to get off your chest
perhaps at the moment?
Anything else
that's on your mind
before I get to that question
that you know I'm going to ask
that you probably
don't want me to ask.
- No. I just I want everybody
to remember how blessed we are
and we've just gone through
what was a traumatic year.
From school closings
to masking, to deaths,
to everything in between.
But that doesn't mean we
have to sink down with it,
I think we can
rise up above that.
If we just showed how
resilient we are again,
we just showed that it
Operation Warp Speed
that they found a vaccine
in less than a year.
We just showed the goodness
of our first responders.
Like so much good and
blessings came out of it,
take that energy and
let's carry that forward.
Don't let all of this negativity
and everything
else bring us down
because we've got a
lot of work to do.
- That could have
been the closing--
- 2022 we got a
lot of work to do
- Ah, 2022.
I want to talk about two
years after that for a second.
You know I have to
ask, I have to ask.
Come on, come on, give me
something, it'll go viral.
- I just don't think I have
to make that decision yet.
I don't, I don't.
I think that the way I look at
is I've never been one
that's thought too far out
but I do think 2022
really important.
We have to win the house, I
think we can win the Senate,
I'm an optimist, we've got
to win some governor's races.
We've got Virginia and
New Jersey up this year.
And so I think there's a
lot of work to be done.
I think that I don't have to
make a decision before then
and I think afterwards
we'll kind of see
where the chips fall,
but it's not something
that I grew up saying,
oh, I have to do this.
No, I have a family.
You think twice about it
when you have a family,
you think twice about it
when you know other people
will be affected and it's not.
Politics is a blood sport,
it's not fun right now.
It's a tough time to be in it.
But right now I feel like
I can do the greatest good
by making sure we win the
house in the Senate back.
And so we're campaigning here,
we're going to be campaigning
for Michelle Steele
and Young Kim, we've endorsed
Marionette Miller-Meeks
and Julia Letlow from Louisiana,
we're going to be helping
candidates all over the country
and we're going to try and
recruit some really good ones
because the ones that won in
this past congressional races,
man, they're good
quality people.
I mean, they are
going to run circles
around Nancy Pelosi and
we need more of that.
- All right.
Well, ambassador, governor,
undeclared
presidential candidate.
- It's Nikki.
Those are moments and times
- It was a pleasure.
It was just so nice
so nice talking to you
and actually seeing
the person again.
- This was a great time.
Thanks for having me.
- Well, thank you so much.
We are not going to link to
that political piece down below
but we will link to Nikki's
book, "With All Due Respect",
which I've got right here
and we'll do more
of these in person.
Wow. All right. Why not?
(upbeat music)
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of nonstop yelling, check
out our politics playlist,
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety
of topics watch our
full episode playlist
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.